Die Hausdurchsuchungen beim Verein Zwiebelfreunde waren rechtswidrig. Das hat das Landgericht München 1 entschieden und kassierte damit Entscheidungen des Amtsgerichts München. Der Verein sammelte Gelder für den E-Mail-Provider Rise Up. Einem Rise Up-Nutzer waren zuvor strafbare Handlungen vorgeworfen worden. Das besondere elektronische Anwaltspostfach BEA soll ab dem 3. September wieder in Betrieb gehen. Die Bundesrechtsanwaltskammer hat das System auf Basis eines Expertengutachtens als sicher erklärt. Anwältinnen und Anwälte müssen das BEA mindestens zum Empfang von Dokumenten nutzen. Der CCC Darmstadt zeigte bereits im Januar gravierende Sicherheitslücken und strukturelle Probleme im BEA auf. Die Deutsche Bahn will ihr Glasfasernetz entlang der Gleise vermarkten. Die Verbindungen dienen der Steuerung des Zugverkehrs, seien damit aber nicht ausgelastet. Verbliebene Kapazitäten sollen für den Breitbandausbau eingesetzt werden. Die Bahn denkt dabei vor allem an Mobilfunk und sucht nach Partnern in der Telekommunikationsbranche.
Und damit Herzlich Willkommen zurück zum Chaosradio 249, wo wir weiter über Mastodon und föderale Systeme sprechen wollen und hatten vor der Pause gerade geklärt, na ja, im Zweifelsfall kann man ja immer weiterziehen. Das heißt, ich kann meinen Account nehmen und irgendwo anders hingehen, auf eine andere Instanz vergleichbar mit, also der Vergleich hinkt wie alle Vergleiche, aber vielleicht vergleichbar mit, ich richte meine neue E-Mail Adresse bei einem anderen Anbieter ein. Jetzt, Leah und oder Rixx, was genau kann ich denn machen? Also mache ich mir einen neuen Account und muss dann von vorne anfangen, also neu den Leuten folgen, mir müssen Leute neu folgen, Inhalte sind mitgenommen oder gehen verloren, also was genau passiert oder kann ich umziehen und was nehme ich dann mit?
Du machst dir erstmal einen ganz normalen neuen Account, wie du es gesagt hast, als wär es dein erster Account. Und du nimmst nicht mit, was du schon gepostet hast, weil du nicht rückwirkend Status absetzen kannst. Also du kannst nicht sagen, dieser Account hat übrigens vor einem Jahr das hier geschrieben. Das ist schwierig, weil sonst könntest du das ja überall hinfaken. Guckt mal, ich habe vor einem Jahr schon vorhergesagt, was heute passieren wird.
Könnte man nicht was mit Blockchain machen?
Alter.
Bitte liebe Hörerinnen und Hörer, entschuldigt diesen Insider-Gag. Wir haben wirklich nicht die Zeit, den zu erklären. Aber gut, okay, das geht also nicht.
Keine Posts? Keine Posts. Du kannst auch nicht einfach so mitnehmen, wer dir folgt. Weil damit, also damit würdest du ja einfach fremd Leuten sagen, du folgst jetzt übrigens einer anderen Person. Das lässt sich ja auch einfach so missbrauchen. Du kannst aber mitnehmen, wem du folgst. Also du kannst eine Liste importieren, also vorher exportieren, und dann wieder importieren und dann hast du die Leute, denen du folgst, wieder da. Und du kannst auf deinem alten Profil ein Redirect-Hinweis anbringen. Also du kannst sagen, dieser Account ist jetzt lahmgelegt, das steht da auch so. Also das ist ein Feature, das ist nicht nur was, was du da so irgendwo halt hinschreibst. Dieser Account ist lahmgelegt, wenn du dem folgen willst, dann klick hier, kommst zum aktuellen.
Aber ich muss ja, also das war nur ein dover Gag mit der Blogschneider, aber ich muss trotzdem mal fragen, gibt es keine Möglichkeit sozusagen einen ein eindeutigen Identifikationsmechanismus zu erzeugen, der halt genau das macht? Also der sagt, okay, da gibt jemand einen Account auf und möchte den umziehen und dass man das dann doch mitnimmt? Also ist das technisch nicht möglich? Oder ist es zu aufwendig, um es umzusetzen?
Das ist technisch sicher möglich, aber nicht umgesetzt, weil es sehr, sehr aufwendig ist, das gut und richtig und nicht missbrauchbar hinzukriegen. Das ist in aktiver Diskussion. Das wirklich wirklich Schöne an Mastodon ist ja nicht nur, dass es dieses abstrakte Konzept von freier offener Software ist, sondern dass es wirklich öffentliche Diskussionen um neue Features gibt. Die sind auf GitHub und man kann da mit voten und mit diskutieren und mit Lösungen vorschlagen. Aber diese Diskussion ist halt bislang zu noch keinem Abschluss gekommen.
Wird denn da wirklich offen diskutiert? Oder trifft letztlich sozusagen dann der Eugen als Wohlwolle, der Diktator, die Entscheidung macht, dass er so wie er will?
Tut er. Ist auch was, was nicht alle deuten super lieb ist. Hat bislang gut genug funktioniert, obwohl es auch, wie gesagt, den einen oder anderen Fog von Mastodon gibt. Aber trotzdem lässt sich an den meisten Stellen mit Argumenten ziemlich weit kommen. Also sonst hätte das so lange nicht zusammengehalten.
Ich will mal zurück zum User umzugehen. Du hast gesagt, man kann so ein Redirect einrichten. Wenn ich jemanden folge, der umzieht, kriege ich dann irgendwie eine Benachrichtigung? Also sagt mir dann mein Mastodon, ey, du folgst jetzt meinen Typen, aber der ist jetzt leider ganz woanders, aber klick doch mal hier. Oder ist das eher so, wenn ich aktiv auf das Profile klicke, weil ich denke, ja Mensch, von dem, was ich lange nichts mehr gehört, dann steht das da irgendwo.
Also ich habe dafür noch nie eine Notification gesehen. Ich glaube, dafür gibt es keine. Aber siehst du, es wäre wieder was, was man als Feature Vorschlag in dieses Mastodon-Repo schubsen könnte und mit gar nicht so schlechten Chancen, dass es passieren würde.
Okay, und kann man sowas einrichten wie, okay, ich habe jetzt einen neuen Account und da soll einfach mein alter Account immer re- Was? Retooten? Retooten. Rebooten, was der neue Account macht.
Das lässt sich, also ich habe dafür noch nichts gesehen, aber dafür einen Bot zu schreiben, der sowas macht, das dürfte ziemlich leicht sein.
Okay, so, dann hätten wir das geklärt, wie da umzugeht. Die eine andere Sache, die ich noch fragen wollte, ihr habt am Anfang gesagt, Henning hat das Beispiel, Cambridge Analytica, also Facebook gibt Daten, die es eigentlich nicht weitergeben soll, an Dritte weiter und das war ein Skandal. Na, die Größe, wenn man sich unbedingt kreiert, so sagen, vielleicht war ich nicht groß genug, aber das kann auf jeden Fall passieren. Jetzt ist das ja eigentlich kein, also ganz hartes Argument für Macedon, weil da fallen ja auch Daten an, die können ja auch weitergegeben werden. Und dazu erstmal noch mal eine technische Frage, weil das habe ich auch wieder häufiger gelesen von neuen Master Newsern. Die Admins einer Instanz können die Direktnachrichten einsehen, technisch, theoretisch. Wir können in die Datenbank gucken und da liegen die im Klartext, also sie sind nicht verschlüsselt. Genau, wie auf Twitter auch. Also der Admin eines Betrebers kann bei solchen Nachdiensten häufig, wenn sie nicht verschlüsselt sind, das sehen. Und bei Mastundes ist das so, das kann nicht nur, also wenn ich Instanz übergreifend kommuniziere, dann können das die Admin bei der Instanz sehen oder beziehungsweise aller beteiligten Instanzen. Richtig? So, das heißt also auch, so und auch wenn, na sag schnell, also die, ich will immer Tweet sagen, die Tuts, ich weiß auch nicht, ob das so eine gute Idee ist, da ein neues Wort zu benutzen. Das heißt, sollte man Tweet einfach so verallgemeinern, für einen Social Media Post ist halt ein Tweet immer Post. Wenn ich also poste, dann kann das ja auch sozusagen auf einer anderen Instanz landen. Das heißt, diese Daten, also so ähnliche Daten wie Facebook da gesammelt hat, können ja hier auch anfallen und können dann auch an Dritte weitergegeben werden. Und alles, was mich sozusagen da verschützt, ist hoffentlich die richtige Instanz ausgewählt zu haben. Und selbst dann weiß ich das ja nicht sicher, weil ich ja diese Daten auch von außen auslesen kann. Also ist das mal Hand aufs Herz wirklich ein Vorteil von Mastodon, dass die Daten in einer wie auch immer gearteten Art und Weise sicherer sind?
Sie sind in der Hinsicht sicherer, dass wir zumindest jetzt sagen, wir machen nichts damit.
Aber nur, wie gesagt, ist es nicht um einen Vorwurf zu machen, sondern das ist eine technische Frage. Ich muss euch genauso vertrauen, wie ich einem Facebook vertraue. Also ich habe sozusagen keinen Einfluss, sondern ich muss euch vertrauen.
Das würde ich sagen, gilt für die Partnachrichten, weil da nicht allen Leuten immer klar ist, dass die nicht komplett privat sind. Auch wenn du schon sagtest, allein dadurch, dass die mit in der normalen Timeline auftauchen, wird einem das etwas klarer und wir bemühen uns auch, das immer wieder klarzustellen. Aber alles andere sind ja Daten, die du öffentlich postest, aktiv von dir aus. Wenn du einen Status veröffentlicht, der öffentlich ist, dann taucht der auf einer Internetseite auf, die Leute sehen können, ohne eingeloggt zu sein. Das taucht in einem öffentlichen RSS-Feed auf. Diese Daten können natürlich auch Leute beliebig abschnorcheln oder als Admins abgreifen, aber das müssen sie nicht mal. Die können einfach auf diese ganzen RSS-Feeds gucken.
Und genauso ist es mit den Dingen, die ich like. Das ist ja auch öffentlich sichtbar.
Das ist richtig. Das ist einer der Vorteile von einem großen Mastodon-Frog. Der hat daneben noch ein privates Bookmark-Feature, das die Likes nicht öffentlich macht. Aber auch bei den Likes ist dir das ja irgendwie klar, weil du ja immer einsehen kannst, wer alles so ein Like auf so einen Status geworfen hat.
Aber das heißt also tatsächlich, mehr Datum ist eigentlich nicht so ein großes Argument, oder Henning?
Wie siehst du das jetzt? Ich finde erstmal ist es natürlich wirklich so, dass ich dem Admin ein bisschen vertrauen muss. Auch dass mein Passwort da irgendwie nicht wegkommt oder dass das gut verschlüsselt ist. Aber ich finde es erstmal gut, wenn sich Oma Erna, wenn sie sich so einen Account aufsetzt, darüber überhaupt mal Gedanken darüber macht, dass sie halt so einem Admin vertrauen muss. Ich befürchte nämlich bei Facebook und GMX und wo sie sich überall einen Account angelegt hat, hat sie sich gar nicht so richtig Gedanken darüber gemacht. Und der zweite Punkt ist natürlich, dass wir jetzt halt verschiedene Instanzen haben. Und der Unterschied zu Facebook ist halt, dass Facebook die Daten von zwei Milliarden Menschen auf diesem Planeten hat, was halt irgendwie ja kaum vergleichbar ist mit kleineren Instanzen. Auch wenn die Mastodonnetz natürlich vom Gesamtmenge her viel kleiner ist. Aber verteilt ist auch schon mal irgendwie besser, was so Unfälle und Daten sind, weggekommen, Vorgänger angeht.
Okay, das funktioniert so lange, wie die Hauptsoftware nicht einen Bug hat, der nicht erkannt und... Na egal, da können wir nachher noch reden. Jetzt möchte ich zum ganz anderen Punkt kommen und einen kurzen Mastodonbreak machen. Weil Hörer der ersten Stunde erinnern sich vielleicht, am Anfang hat er doch noch jemanden vorgestellt. Da sitzt doch noch ein A-Tor. Was war denn da eigentlich los? Wir haben jetzt die ganze Zeit über Mastodon als ein Beispiel. Und ja, das hat heute sehr viel Platz eingenommen, weil es einfach gerade in aller Munde ist. Zumindest in der Tech Bubble. Aber ist halt eben ein Beispiel für ein föderalisiertes System. Wir haben bei manchen Gesellungen gesagt, wir wollen auch über Nextcloud reden, was auch so ein Beispiel dafür ist. Und da fragt man sich ja Moment mal, Nextcloud, das ist doch so ein Ding, da kann ich irgendwie Dateien zwischen meinen Rechnern synchronisieren und die auch für Dritte freigeben. Was genau hat das jetzt mit diesem föderalen System zu tun? Und das wird uns Arthur jetzt erklären. Arthur, wieso ist Nextcloud auch ein föderales System? Also was bedeutet das in diesem Zusammenhang?
Ja, das bedeutet auch ähnlich wie bei den ganzen Masterron Instanzen, dass sich jeder seine Nextcloud Instanz aufziehen kann. Das soll jetzt auch wieder jeder in Anführungsstrichen. Und darüber auch eben seine Dateien dann mit anderen teilen kann, sodass darüber daran gearbeitet werden kann.
Ich will nur versuchen, das ganz genau zu verzeihen. Also dass ich mir eine eigene Nextcloud aufsetze, das ist ja sowieso die grundlegende Idee dieses Dienstes. Also das Ding ist ja, also die Idee ist ja genau, das ist also hier, bei Mastodon ist das große Vorbild Facebook und Twitter, bei Nextcloud ist es halt Google Drive oder Dropbox. Nämlich da gibt es den zentralen Anbieter, wo ich Dateien zwischen den Rechnern synchronisieren kann und sie für Dritte freigeben. Das macht Nextcloud auch und die Idee ist halt, ich installiere die im Zweifel auf dem Raspberry Pi unter meinem Schreibtisch oder auf meinem eigenen Webseiter, wie auch immer. Und kann ja dann auch Dateien an Dritte freigeben, entweder indem ich so einen Link generiere auch, wo ich sage, hier klickt ihr den Link, etc. oder indem ich ihn einlade, macht ihr einen Account bei mir und dann schreibe ich die Rechte zu. Aber das ist ja noch nicht Föderalismus.
Ja, Föderalismus. Na, es geht am Ende dahin, dass du, wie gesagt, du hast deine Instanzen. Im Wesentlichen macht das Sinn für irgendwelche Organisationen, ganz im Kleinen, vielleicht für Familien, wo dann halt auch eben andere Angebote wie der Kalender verwendet werden zusammen, bis zu Vereinen, Firmen, Schulen, etc. Dann geht es darum, wie sich diese Instanzen vernetzen können. Da gibt es ein Modell, dass man gegenseitig auch User woanders finden kann. Dazu gibt es noch eine Komponente, die sich Lookup Server nennt, die fest konfiguriert ist, was man sich aufsetzen kann. Und wenn man sein Profildaten entsprechend einstellt, andere darüber auch finden kann. Das ist aber nicht zwingend vorgeschrieben. Es ist eher so ein Opt-in und man selber kann aktiv Dateien und Ordner über diese federierte Schnittstelle dann mit ganz speziellen anderen Benutzern oder neuerdings auch Gruppen teilen.
Okay und das Föderale daran ist, dass ich, wenn ich, also ich kann ja bei NextLoud immer Dateien frei gegenüber den Link und ich kann ja aber auch einem Nutzer, der bei mir ist, bestimmte Rechte einräumen und der föderale Gedanke ist, ich kann das auch mit Nutzern machen, die woanders eine NextLoud haben.
Ja genau, okay vielleicht ist nicht klar geworden, sorry. Ja genau, wenn ich kann dort im Dialog zum Teilen eben einer Datei, kann ich dich auf deine Instanz da eintragen und darüber wird dann die Anfrage an dich gestellt. Hier Arto möchte gerade diese Datei mit der Teilen annehmen, damit du auch nicht gefloidet wirst.
Gespammt.
Gespammt wirst, genau.
Hier möchten sie diesen Flyer für diesen unfassbar tollen Staubsaugerteil.
Ja genau, und dann kannst du eben das ablehnen oder annehmen und dann erscheint, wenn du das annimmst, erscheint diese Datei dann bei dir in deinem Nextcloud. Wenn du die Synchronisations-Client benutzt, dann an dir dann auch gegebenenfalls auf deinem Smartphone oder auf deinem Laptop, dann kannst du halt damit da ganz normal auch mitarbeiten. Ich kann dir, genau, Berechtigungen mitgeben. Entweder, dass du das eigentlich nur ansehen darfst, dann darfst du das halt eben nicht zurückschreiben oder dich auch da editieren lassen, wenn du jetzt an einem Textdokument zusammenarbeiten möchtest.
Du bist ja Entwickler auch bei Nextout. Kannst du einen Einblick oder einen groben Überblick darüber geben? Wie gesagt, nicht im technischen Detail, aber inwieweit das eine Software komplizierter macht, wenn sie halt dieses föderale System auch hat? Also mit anderen Instanzen derselben Software übers Netz zu reden. Ist das so, ja gut, irgendwie User generieren kann man sowieso, dann User von anderen Instanzen ist da auch egal oder ist das noch mal relevant viel Arbeit?
Das Ziel letztendlich ist, das Ganze auch tatsächlich so einfach zu machen, dass das für Benutzer keine große Rolle mehr spielt, dass die irgendwie ganz bewusst eine ganz komplizierte E-Mail-Adresse eingeben, sondern es soll dahin gehen, dass man das einfach benutzender macht, dass es sich für den End-User, der nicht so technisch großartifiziert ist, dass es da möglichst einfach funktioniert.
Ja, das finde ich auch ein sehr lohnenswertes Ziel. Aber was ich eigentlich meinte ist, wie hoch ist der Aufwand in der Entwicklung der Software? Weil die Software muss ja jetzt etwas mehr können. Und ich kann sozusagen als Leier von außen nicht sagen, ist das, man baut da irgendwie noch, keine Ahnung, 30 Zeilen Code an, dann ist das getan, oder ist das nochmal ein relevanter Punkt der Softwarearchitektur und sehr, sehr viel Arbeit, das zu realisieren, dass die Software auch untereinander reden kann.
Ja, natürlich ist es einfacher, wenn man irgendwie einfach nur so einen geschlossenen Kreis hätte, dann müsste man sich keine Gedanken machen, wie sieht halt eine Schnittstelle aus, die halt irgendwie da vernünftig ist. Insofern muss sich darüber Gedanken gemacht werden, wie kann es am besten funktionieren, dass das vielleicht auch nicht missbraucht wird, dass man das irgendwie gut verwenden kann, dass...
Was mich zum Beispiel interessieren würde ist, solange ich nutze nur auf meiner eigenen Software, also ich habe eine Nextalk Installation, da kann ich User anlegen und diese User können auch untereinander interagieren mit diesen ganzen Möglichkeiten und haben nicht das Problem von verschiedenen Versionen, sondern meine Software hat eine Version. Wenn ich jetzt mit der Software von Tante Emma, mit der Nextcloud von Tante Emma noch irgendwie kommuniziere, dann hat die möglicherweise, oder vielleicht auch ich, vielleicht war ich faul und habe die letzten drei Patches nicht eingespielt. Inwieweit ist das ein Problem oder ist es sozusagen, solange man diese Komponente, die für die Kommunikation nicht verändert, dann ist es egal?
Ja, hier geht es am Ende um die Schnittstelldefinition, API auf Entwicklersprech. Da ist es wichtig, dass die gegebenenfalls versioniert wird und ansonsten, dass sie rückwärts compatible bleibt.
Das heißt, meine aktuelle Reversion fragt die andere an und die sagt dann, ja ich bin alt und die aktuelle Reversion sagt, kein Problem, ich weiß noch, wie ich mit dir reden kann. Und inwieweit ist das von der Security her? Dann noch mal aufwendiger?
Aufwendiger? Letztendlich muss man. Natürlich, da liegt es am Ende am Empfänger, ob er die Datei tatsächlich annehmen möchte, ob er dir auch vertraut, dass das keine Schadsoftware ist oder sowas. Da muss man natürlich auch wissen, ob er dem Benutzer, der da sind, vertrauen kann. Auch da gibt es natürlich andere Mittel und Wege, das dann ein bisschen einfacher zu machen. Es gibt diverse Apps, die jetzt noch Ransomware entdecken möchten oder so was. Spamfilter oder so, aber idealerweise ja.
Aber da geht es um die übertragenen Dateien. Musst du diese Schnittstelle geben, von der du gesprochen hast? Die ist natürlich ein Angriffspunkt, wie jeder Softwarebestandteil ein Angriffspunkt ist. Aber ist das extra gefährlich?
Es ist ein weiterer Punkt, der natürlich irgendwie angegriffen kann. Andererseits unterscheidet sich dann aber nicht wirklich von der weiteren Entwicklung. Zum einen haben wir grundsätzlich automatisierten Checks, die irgendwo in einem Malayer, in der Chefsoftware, versteckt sind, dass sich der Entwickler des Endpunktes jetzt darüber nicht so viele Gedanken machen muss, außer dass er halt tatsächlich irgendwelche Features freischalten muss. In dem Fall muss er erlauben, dass der Endpunkt auch von Nicht-Administratoren erreicht werden kann. Also das sind die striktesten Vorgaben, erstmal Standard und alles andere muss runtergebrochen werden. Also das unterscheidet sich dann jetzt eigentlich nicht von allen anderen Endpunkten, die man dann auch macht.
Und habt ihr den Überblick darüber, wie weit das als Feature genutzt wird?
Na, wir selbst, bei uns selbst fallen eigentlich keine Daten an, ist das nicht?
Aber ihr kriegt ja wahrscheinlich irgendwie Nutzerinnen-
und Nutzerfeedback. Das ist eigentlich aus einer anderen Perspektive noch mal viel interessanter, wenn es darum geht, wie man die Nextcloud so skalieren kann, dass Millionen von uns dann weltweit das benutzen können. Und mit der üblichen Architektur, da kann man das halt auch weit treiben, wenn man halt genug Loadbalancer davor haut und Daten anklasset, etc. Irgendwann wird es dann auch zu viel. Und dann ist dann die Idee, dass man die User auch die verschiedenen Instanzen verteilt und die unter anderem mit dem Federated Sharing auch anbinden kann.
Also das heißt, du sagst, dass ich als große Firma irgendwie nicht hingehe und mir eine große Nextcloud baue, sondern eher viele kleine und die können untereinander interagieren.
Genau. Das sind noch ein paar andere Komponenten zu, sodass das alles auch einheitlich aussieht. Aber im Grunde ist es dann auch dieses.
Jetzt haben wir sozusagen ein zweites Beispiel gehabt. Und jetzt würde ich gerne um einmal fragen, was ist für euch noch eine Technologie, die föderalisiert ist und die ihr wichtig findet? Also ich sitze gerade und denke so, verhältst du die Frage eigentlich stellen sollen, weil so viele kommen gar nicht mehr zusammen. Aber mal sehen, du hast doch noch ein andere, sozusagen föderalisiertes Software, wo du denkst, das ist ein super Ding, das ist eine super Idee gewesen. Also außer Mastodon, außer E-Mail, außer Nextcloud, außer Java.
Ja, wenn ich ganz am Anfang mal gesagt hab, Diaspora ist ja auch irgendwie noch da. Das ist halt so ein bisschen eher so ein Mischmasch vielleicht aus Mastodon, Twitter und Facebook. Das lebt ja auch noch vor sich hin. Und das ist ja quasi so mein Zuhause bisher.
Also ich habe das Gefühl, dass Diaspora eher das Google Plus oder das Google Wave ist noch böse. Aber Henning, hast du noch etwas zu sagen?
Es ist nicht unbedingt eine Software, aber ich meine eigentlich beim Telefonieren ist es ja eigentlich auch so. Ich habe vielleicht irgendwie eine Technologie, wo ich einen Anbieter habe, zum Beispiel jetzt im Bifunk bei der Telekom. Wenn du ein O2-Vertrag hast, dann kann ich dich trotzdem anrufen, weil es ein Protokoll gibt, einen gemeinsamen Standard, auf dem diese Anbieter sich verabredet haben, da zu peeren oder wie auch immer. Und dann kann ich dich anrufen und wir können miteinander telefonieren.
Also ich finde es ein bisschen gecheatet, weil es eine sehr alte Technologie ist, aber ich finde es sehr gut, dass du es gesagt hast, weil eigentlich hätte man es damit erklären sollen.
Das ist ein Beispiel für diese Interoperabilität, über die wir jetzt sprechen.
Vielleicht solltest du in Zukunft moderieren.
Was bezahlt ihr denn hier?
Hier, bezahlen. Über Geld reden wir auch gleich nochmal. Leah, was findest du für eine federale Technologie, die du wichtig findest?
Gute Frage. Ich hatte mir jetzt das Java erst mal aufgedacht. Ehrlich gesagt müsste ich jetzt gerade ein bisschen nachdenken. Ich habe ISC, anderes Chatprotokoll.
Wo man auch eine eigene Server aufsetzen kann. Ist das tatsächlich federal? Kann ich damit Leuten auf anderen IRC-Servern reden?
Es kommt drauf an.
Wir haben eine Wortmeldung aus dem Publikum bzw. vom Mischpult. Aber wir hören den nicht.
Der Mensch am Mischpult hat noch eine Idee. Und zwar das Internet.
Das Internet. Meinst du jetzt das World Wide Web?
Genau, da kommunizieren ja auch verschiedene autonome Systeme. Also IS miteinander, die keinen zentralen Server haben. Klar, man kann sagen, es gibt zentrale Instanzen, z.B. die RIPE. Aber die Systeme versee kommunizieren ja federiert.
Also ich fürchte, das ist als Beispiel an dieser Stelle ein bisschen schwierig, weil man nochmal ganz genau erklären müsste, wie das Internet eigentlich funktioniert. Dazu gibt es ein Chaosradio. Ich hab die Nummer nicht, aber den Show notes wird es bestimmt verlinkt. Aber okay, das Internet. Rixx, hast du vielleicht noch ein kleines, besser verständliches Beispiel?
Ich glaube, durch besser verständliche Beispiele sind wir durch. Ich war auch versucht, irgendwas wie DNS zu sagen, nicht? Weil das ist technisch gesehen auch federiert. Und man kann natürlich in der Politik Graben gehen, wo man sagen könnte, ich war Federated Federal Republic. Das steckt ja gewissermaßen im Namen. Aber was die Erklärung eher leichter als schwerer macht, habe ich jetzt nicht.
Vielleicht kann ich noch eine andere Frage stellen ganz kurz an dich. Gibt es eine Technologie in der Zukunft, wo du denkst, die müsste eigentlich federiert werden? Nein, anscheinend nicht.
Na, schon irgendwie alles, was Kommunikation betrifft. Es ist ja kein Zufall, dass das gerade in diesen sozialen Netzwerken und in E-Mails nicht.
Das stimmt.
Das heißt, gerade alles, was auch direkte Messaging-Systeme wären.
Also sowas wie WhatsApp oder Threema oder Signal oder was auch immer.
Ja, aber es gibt doch auch jetzt so Ideen, YouTube auf dezentral zu machen. Da gibt es auch dieses PeerTube.
Das ist ja schon. Das habe ich jetzt noch mit unter Fediverse gerechnet. Das habe ich gedacht.
Aber ich glaube, aus Anwendersicht haben wir bisher so diskutiert, so Mastodon ist so die Twitter-Alternative. Und dann gibt es aber noch ein paar andere Apps, die sehr angesagt sind wie WhatsApp und YouTube. Und da kann man auch was.
Also werde ich mir das beim Messenger ganz gut vorstellen kann, dass man das macht, weil die E-Mail- und Telefonanalogie da gut funktioniert. Bin ich mir bei Video-Serving sozusagen nicht wirklich sicher, ob das was ist, wo man Nutzerinnen und Nutzer davon sagen kann, dass das da sinnvoll ist. Weil so ein One-Stop-Shop für alle Bewegt-Bild-Inhalte, also was auch immer man politisch davon halten mag, bin ich mir nicht ganz sicher, wie gut das gehen kann. Aber eine der wichtigen Dinge, die bei diesem ganzen Föderalismus-Zeug eben wichtig sind, ist ja auch, dass man das aufsetzen kann. Darüber reden wir gleich. Vorher noch eine kleine Musikpause, ein Video von Timecrawler, diesmal mit Streetdancing. Streetdancing von Timecrawler und damit begeben wir uns in den Endspurt des Chaosradios 249, wo wir über föderale Systeme sprechen. Und jetzt natürlich wissen wollen, wie weit ist es denn her mit, das kann ja jeder. Also die Idee ist ja eben gerade, dass es verschiedene Instanzen von föderaler Software gibt, also nicht nur von Mastodon, sondern generell Nextcloud auch, Email, was auch immer. Und ich kann nur zwei Enauguten von mir erzählen. Das eine ist, ich habe noch nie eine Nextcloud Instanz betrieben, aber eine Owncloud Instanz mal selber installiert auf einem Raspberry Pi unter meinem Schreibtisch. Das ist ein Jahr lang gut gegangen und danach ist zweimal in kurzer Folge hintereinander ein Akana-Fehler, der irgendwas mit dem Dateisystem zu tun hatte und mir die Datenbank zerschossen hatte. Und alleine dieser Satz hat mir dann gezeigt, ich habe da einfach keine Lust mehr drauf. Das ist einfach zu viel Aufwand. Und das andere ist, als Mastodon aufkam, habe ich mal geguckt, wie könnte ich mir da aber selber so eine Instanz zulegen. Das ist ja, also ich meine, ein Software, der man installieren kann. Und dann habe ich irgendwas von Linux-Servern und Jason, weiß ich nicht genau. Also das zu sagen, das war schon vom Einmal-An-Gucken zu kompliziert, als dass ich da selber hätte was machen wollen. Wie sieht es denn bei Nextcloud aus? Kann das mittlerweile jeder? Ist das einfach eine Software auf einem Rechner auspacken und dann läuft das? Oder muss man dafür Fachwissen haben?
Ja, so ganz einfach wird es nie werden, wenn man das wirklich von Hand installieren möchte, weil da immer noch Komponenten wie die Web-Server und die Datenbank da sind und die PHP-Laufzeit. Von daher, wenn man auf diese Schiene möchte, da muss man sich schon ein bisschen mit auskennen. Es gibt aber auch noch, gibt oder wird auch noch ein paar andere Wege geben, wie man das betreiben kann. Also zum einen gibt es manche Software-Anbieter oder Distributionen, bei denen das relativ einfach geht, wo man das mit einem Klick fast nahezu installieren kann. Aus dem eher geschäftsmäßigen Bereich haben wir, oder habe ich da auch, die Integration in den Univention Corporate Server als Beispiel, wo das halt, also es ist halt auch eine Linux-Distribution. Und da kann man es installieren und dann kann man sich einloggen und dann läuft das und dann wird es auch automatisch, oder fast automatisch geupdatet.
Aber das kostet dann Geld, das ist dann quasi ein Abo-Modell oder was?
Für den privaten Gebrauch haben die das auch für Ume.
Genau, aber dann liegt das auf dem Rechner eines anderen Menschen.
Nee. Nee, da musst du halt die sogenannte Appliance oder das selbst installieren. Das läuft aber auf deine Maschine, ist dann relativ wartungsfrei.
Aber meine Maschine steht in einem Rechnungszentrum, also sie steht nicht bei mir zu Hause, oder wie?
Das kann auch bei dir zu Hause stehen, ja. Also wie gesagt, das ist eine Rechnungsdistribution, die halt ein bisschen spezialisierter ist. Der Univention Corporate Server.
Und das ist ein Paket, das kann ich installieren, oder läuft da eine Nextcloud Instanz drauf?
Wie gesagt, also das ist eine Rechnungsdistribution, hier müsste man sich installieren, aber das geht relativ einfach, wenn man sich durch den Standard dadurch klickt. Das ist so ein Beispiel, es gibt noch andere Softwareanbieter, die dir halt auch sowas bereitstellen. In Japan, für Japan hat NEC angekündigt, dass er demnächst die Router, die man halt zu Hause stehen hat, mit Nextcloud besticken möchte. Die haben auch eine schöne Internetanbindung dort und dann wird es da halt relativ nett funktionieren wohl.
Na gut, aber da muss ja wieder auch ein Gerät kaufen. Leah, du bist ja für den technischen Teil im Hintergrund zuständig. Kannst du kurz sagen, was man alles haben muss, bevor man eine laufende Mastodon-Instanz am Start hat?
Was man haben muss, man braucht halt irgendwie eine Kiste mit ausreichend Ressourcen und Anbindung vor allem auch. Und das reicht theoretisch, technisch gesehen.
Ich meine sozusagen, was man da alles installieren muss.
Es ist eine lange Liste und ich glaube, das hilft.
Okay, verstehe.
Dementsprechend ist es, sagen wir so eine Software, so eine Web-Applikation, auch funktioniert ja nicht alleine.
Okay, dann lasst es mich andersrum fragen. Normalerweise versuchen wir immer alles zu erklären, aber kannst du, wenn du sozusagen einem auf Augenhöhe operierenden Admin-Kollegen, der die Software nicht kennt, aber sozusagen deinen technischen Stand hat, wenn du dem sagst, was sind die Dinge, die man braucht, um eine Mastodon-Instanz zu installieren, wie würde das klingen?
Vermutlich würde ich ihm einfach sagen, hier guck mal, ich hab eine fertige Ansprillrolle, benutze doch einfach die. Das ist im Prinzip Automatisierung. Praktisch ist es aber, er braucht eben eine Datenbank, eventuell noch was, was ein bisschen zwischendurch cashed, damit nicht alles komplett direkt ausgeliefert werden muss. Es braucht eine Webserver, es braucht die Software, also Mastodon selbst. Und das war es im Prinzip auch im Großen und Ganzen schon.
Okay, worin ist sie geschrieben?
Die ist in Ruby on Rails geschrieben.
Ah, okay, das heißt, damit ist es für Endanwender, die bei einem Web-Poster irgendwas sich zusammenklicken können, raus, weil die meistens kein Ruby on Rails können. Ja, ich meine so per Klick. Also ich hab einen Web-Poster, da kann man einfach klicken, installieren mit WordPress. Und das kann der für verschiedene Softwarearten, aber halt nicht. Das ist halt alles dann PHP, glaube ich, und nichts, was irgendwie Ruby on Rails kann.
Ich glaube, mich immer erinnern zu können, dass es für Mastodon sogar auch so ein One-Click-Hoster gab.
Tatsächlich, es gibt zumindest einen Dienst, der das anbietet, dass man, glaube ich, für einen fünferen Monat sich eine eigene Mastodon-Instanz da bucht, aber der ist dann spezialisiert genau darauf. Aber das bringt uns ja sozusagen zum Problem. Also beides, was wir jetzt gehört haben, es ist halt schon was für, sagen wir mal, Profis. Oder anderswo Henning, du hast ja gesagt, irgendwie so großes Interesse an diesem Dienst im Sinne der, oder in der Idee der Wissenschaftskommunikation, eigener Server aufsetzen. Was willst du mal versuchen?
Also ich persönlich möchte da auf gar keinen Fall admin sein. Ich bin irgendwie damit ausgelastet, bei so einem Web-Poster, wie du ihn beschrieben hast, so einen WordPress zu administrieren. Und das ist oberkante Unterkiefer für meine technischen Fähigkeiten. Aber wir als Wissenschaftsorganisation, finde ich, könnten das schon machen. Und wir haben natürlich eine IT-Abteilung, die das kann oder die halt einen technischen Dienstleister hat, dem man beauftragen könnte, so was zu tun. Und ja, ich stelle mir in der Tat die Frage, ob wir das nicht machen sollten. Da gibt es aber noch ein paar ungelöste Fragen, um die ich gerade...
Welche? Juristische zum Beispiel.
Gibt es da eigentlich was von Podcasts?
Ich weiß es nicht genau. Aber das ist tatsächlich eine interessante Frage. Also es gibt jetzt diese Datenschutzgrundverordnung, vor der alle eine Einheit und Respekt haben. Aber es ist ja nicht erst seitdem, dass man sich Gedanken um andere Leute Daten machen muss, wenn man so eine Systeme betreibt. Wie ist denn das bei Nextcloud eigentlich? Spätestens in dem Moment, wo ich die Software nicht nur für mich selbst benutze, sondern auch öffne in andere Bereiche, müsste ich ja zumindest als Betreiber da auch eine juristische Idee haben. Im Idealfall. Ist das was, was ihr mitdenkt und den Nutzerinnen und Nutzern auch mitgibt?
Oder ist das sozusagen, ja, aber da muss ich halt jeder selber kümmern? Ja klar, wir denken auch damit. Und inzwischen gibt es auch Optionen, dass man da eben noch so ein Impresso, ein Privacy Statement da verlinken kann. Es gibt Apps, eine App, mit der man beim Administrator dann fragen kann, dass man sich die Daten rauszieht, bitte. Oder eben den Account löscht. Aber als erstes einmal versuchen wir überall so weit wie möglich mit offenen Standards zu arbeiten. Speziell bei den Dateien erst mal hier, dass es halt web darf. Das heißt, wenn man sich die rausziehen möchte, dann geht das halt sofort im Kalender, im Kontakt, im Adressbuch ebenfalls. Von daher, alles was den Export so betrifft, das geht auf diese Art und Weise. Und für den Rest, wenn halt irgendwie die Anfrage da ist, dann müsste der Administrator so ein bisschen seine Datenbankkenntnisse da bemühen.
Okay, also das ist auch für Expert-Messen. Rixx und Leah, habt ihr euch mal Gedanken gemacht? Es gibt diese Chaos Social Instanz, die ist ein paar tausend User und Userinnen schwer, wenn ich mich richtig erinnere. Habt ihr euch schonmal über die juristische Komponente oder habt ihr euch da irgendwie darauf vorbereitet oder seid ihr jetzt gerade froh unter Nickname hier zu operieren?
Grundsätzlich ist einer der wichtigen Punkte, wir versuchen allgemein, wie das im Chaos eigentlich anliegen ist, so wenig Daten wie möglich zu speichern. Das heißt, zum Beispiel haben wir selbst das Ganze noch so ein bisschen erweitert, dass wir zum Beispiel alle IP-Adressen, die irgendwo gespeichert werden, rausschmeißen. Das heißt, wir setzen uns schon dafür ein und versuchen, so wenig Daten wie möglich zu speichern. Zum Beispiel gibt es auch eine Suche für Mastodon, die man theoretisch aktivieren kann, aber da sagen wir auch, damit fangen wir eben an, die Daten auszuwäßen. Dann bedienen wir uns auf ganz dünnes Eis und das wollen wir einfach nicht.
Aber zwischen sozusagen dem Datenschutzideal aus dem Chaos-Umfeld und den juristischen Anforderungen an einen betriebenen Online-Service gibt es ja noch zwei Unterschiede.
Da muss man einfach sagen, wir versuchen so weit wie möglich das Ganze natürlich zu erfüllen. Das sind wir natürlich auch verpflichtet. Aber es gibt eben Dinge, da ist es schwierig, weil uns einfach die Software das nicht ganz zulässt.
Okay, das ist noch Neuland sozusagen.
Genau, das ist einfach die Problematik, die alle haben vor der Stelle, natürlich genauso.
Aber wir bemühen uns schon, die ordentlich anzugehen. Also wir kommunizieren das auch an die Leute auf der Instanz natürlich transparent. Aber wir haben ja schon von uns aus Schritte ergriffen, dass halt noch weniger Daten anfallen als eh schon. Mehr können wir an der Stelle nicht machen.
Jetzt ist ja so eine der Sachen, jetzt ist die Sendung schon wieder fast rum. Und den wichtigsten Punkt haben wir noch gar nicht besprochen. Die Idee an einem dezentralen System ist ja, dass das System dezentral ist. Das heißt, es gibt möglichst viele Leute, die Instanzen oder Server oder was auch immer betreiben. Jetzt haben wir schon in zwei oder drei Stellen in der Sendung immer gesagt, ja, JavaCCC.de war so ein Beispiel. Und um das jetzt zu erklären, ist es ja, es gibt Java, einen Chatdienst, der auch dezentral funktionieren kann. Und was in Deutschland, in dem Umfeld sozusagen passiert ist, theoretisch könnte es ganz viele 1000 Java Server geben. Praktisch waren, sagen wir mal betrieben, alle Leute auf JavaCCC.de. Und wenn der sozusagen mal offline war, dann war halt Java in Deutschland tot, mehr oder weniger. Daran kann man halt gut sehen, dass es halt eine geile Idee ist, die zentrale Dienste zu haben. Jetzt haben wir aber gerade schon festgestellt, es ist aber schwierig, die zu administrieren. Was haltet ihr denn für eine gute Größe? Also habt ihr zum Beispiel bei Chaos Social, denkt ihr euch so, naja, um diesen selben Effekt zu verhindern, müssten wir vielleicht eine Begrenzung einführen, wir machen Schluss bei 5.000 Leuten oder was auch immer.
AT-AT. Wir hatten schon ein paar Mal zugemacht, also wir hatten ein paar Mal schon tatsächlich die Registrierung geschlossen. Zum Beispiel jetzt beim letzten Mal, als Twitter irgendwie was Größeres geändert hat, da hatten wir unsere Registrierung nochmal kurz aufgemacht. Dummerweise, es gibt noch die Seite joinmustodon.org, das ist so eine Suchmaschine für welche Instanzen möchte ich eigentlich, mit welchen Instanzen möchte ich eigentlich haben oder was passt zu mir. Und leider sind wir da für deutschsprachig überall als erstes aufgetaucht. Das heißt, plötzlich kamen ganz, ganz viele Leute auch aus eben nicht diesem Chaosumfeld dazu. Und dementsprechend musste man eben dann auch einfach gucken, wie steuert man das, damit die Community eben noch erhalten bleibt und das dann nicht einfach...
Nee, aber das meine ich gar nicht so genau. Also ich habe dann auch gelesen, ihr macht jetzt zu, weil die eigene Community, lokale Teilnehmer sozusagen, soll nur organisch wachsen. Aber meine Frage bezieht sich darauf, was glaubt ihr, was eine gute Größe für eine Instanz ist, damit sichergestellt wird, dass es halt nicht nur eine Instanz gibt, sondern halt viele.
Das hängt doch immer von dem Umfeld ab, das du betrachtest, ne? Also ich meine, die Instanzgröße wird ja eh in absoluten Nutzern angegeben und Nutzerinnen, was überhaupt nicht hilft, weil eigentlich interessieren ja nur die Aktiven.
Okay, Jitsi ist anscheinend der Ansicht, die Sendung ist jetzt bald zu Ende, was tatsächlich auch bald passieren könnte.
Es ist eine andere Größe als für uns.
Das Problem ist nicht nur, dass wir Rixx nicht mehr hören, sondern er anscheinend auch nicht hört, dass ich versuche zu sagen, dass wir ihn gar nicht mehr hören. Das ist leider ein großes Problem.
Ich hab's ihm mal gesagt.
Sehr gut, das ist Föderation. Alle reden irgendwie miteinander. Henning, hast du dazu eine Meinung?
Ja, also ich finde es natürlich super, dass Rixx und Leah als private Enthusiasten und Nerds hier sowas betreiben. Ich finde aber auch, dass viele Leute das privat machen könnten. Dass aber auch gesellschaftliche Player, wie zum Beispiel wir in der Wissenschaft, uns überlegen sollten, sollen wir das nicht machen. Aber auch andere gesellschaftliche Organisationen, gewerkschaften, Kirchen, Verbände, NGOs, Fußballvereine.
Aber die spannende Frage ist ja genau sagen, welche Größe soll das haben. Du hast im Vorgespräch erzählt, es gibt für andere digitale Dienste innerhalb des Forschungsnetzwerkes einen Anbieter, der dann für alle Unis in Deutschland ist. Die Gefahr bestünde ja, wenn man das macht und sagt, okay, machen wir auch, dass das auch passiert. Ist das nicht schon eigentlich zu groß?
Na ja, weiß ich nicht, ob jetzt sozusagen die Wissenschaft irgendwie so ein gesellschaftlicher Player ist im Vergleich zu die Fußballinteressierten oder die Feministinnen. Aus meiner Sicht könnten all solche Organisationen, Verbände, Interessengruppen auch sich fragen, sollen wir nicht auch da mitmachen und so einen Server aufsetzen. Und das betrifft auch nicht nur Mastodon. Ich finde, man sollte auch über andere kommende Systeme nachdenken, also die, die jetzt noch gar nicht entwickelt sind. Wir brauchen ja nicht nur Twitter-Klone in dezentralen Social Media Infrastrukturen, sondern wir brauchen auch Chat Software. Da müssen wir über ganz viele Dinge nachdenken, aus meiner Sicht.
Aber du würdest das ansetzen auf institutioneller Ebene. Man könnte ja auch sagen, Idealforstellung ist, hinter dem Router steht in jedem Zuhause so eine Instanz. Da würdest du sagen, das ist vielleicht eine Nummer zu kleinteilig, lieber auf einer sozusagen eine Ebene größer.
Nee, ich meine auch, ich finde es super, wenn Privatleute wie Rixx und Leah das betreiben. Dieses Netz in Bürgerhand, finde ich eigentlich eine Supervision. Warum nicht? Aber ich fürchte, ich wäre damit überfordert und könnte das nicht. Ich würde vor allem nicht mir zutrauen, dann irgendwelche meinen Freunden zu sagen, kommt zu mir, bei mir sind eure Passwörter sicher. Wären sie wahrscheinlich nicht.
Da komme ich wieder zu dem Bild, das ich ab und zu habe, wenn wir über so digitalen Kram diskutieren, denn eigentlich sind wir doch alle noch in dieser Stammeszeit. Vielleicht hat jeder in seinem näheren Umfeld eine Nerdin oder eine Nerd, die so etwas kennen können und die dann so eine Instanz betreiben. Und die sind quasi der Schamane des Stammes. Es gibt das Dorf, das digitale Dorf, da gibt es den einen Schamanen. Und der wird halt irgendwie die Mastodon Instanz dann betreiben. Wie würdest du das denn sehen, Arthur? In welcher Größenordnung so was passieren kann? Oder andersrum, wie kann man denn sicherstellen, dass dezentral wirklich dezentral bedeutet und halt nicht wieder sozusagen das eine oder zwei große zentrale Server gibt?
Ja, wäre natürlich gut, wenn da so eine Art Regulation stattfindet. Das, was ja eben irgendwie in diesem industriellen Sektor, sag ich jetzt mal, fehlt. Ja, Rick und Leah, die versuchen das ja mit so Selbstregulierung. Ob das jetzt überall so klappt, ist wahrscheinlich eher auch so ein Ideal. Sonst würden wir das ja woanders so sehen. Ja, aber am Ende, weiß nicht, wird es darauf irgendwie hinauslaufen, dass man über irgendwelche Mittel und Wege, dass ich das so selbst regulieren soll. Weiß nicht, vielleicht gibst du was von Blockchain oder so.
Der Markt wird es schon regeln, meinst du.
Nee, der Markt bestimmt nicht, sondern da brauchst du irgendwie andere Instanzen, dass man das halt gesellschaftlich auf die Reihe kriegt.
Soll ich noch ganz kurz was anfangen? Tobi schrieb nämlich mir gerade noch was. Also man muss sagen, es ist gefühlt bei Masterton und auch bei anderen Communities, ich war auch im Freifunkumfeld aktiv. Muss man sagen, so ein guter dreistelliger, eine gute dreistellige Zahl bis, wenn man es mal wirklich in Zahlen festmacht, bis eine höhere vierstellige Zahl, das ist so realistisch. Danach entfremdet sich das ein bisschen untereinander.
Also danach ist es dann keine Community mehr, sondern?
Da gefühlt geht da so ein bisschen dieses, hey, ich gucke jetzt mal in die lokale Timeline und da finde ich jemanden, wenn ich rede, dann passiert da einfach auch ein bisschen zu viel, um das einfach zu überblicken zu können.
Okay, so ein Dorf, wo es so ein paar Tausend Leute groß ist, damit kann man dann auch leben. Wir sind da am Schluss, ich hätte voll gerne noch geredet, wie das eigentlich mit der Finanzierung ist, weil das ist ja sicher ein nicht ungeregendes Problem. Mir wird gerade noch ein Schild hingehalten, was ich nicht lesen kann, aber ich glaube, es bedeutet, dass wir noch über Masterdown-Accounts reden sollen, was ich es sowieso machen wollte. Ich möchte mich gerne von meinen Gästen verabschieden, also Rixx, Leah, Arthur und Henning, und zum Schluss noch nach euren Masterdown-Accounts fragen, oder wenn ihr die nicht sagen wollt, weil ihr die lieber ganz im eigenen halten wollt, einen empfehlen, den man vielleicht folgen kann. Arthur, hast du schon einen Masterdown-Account eingerichtet während der Sendung?
Ich hab's während der Sendung jetzt noch nicht viel geschafft. Aber ich mach's in die Tage, denke ich mal, und dann kommt das vielleicht auf pot.graspora.de, u slash blizz, bli und 3z nachlesen.
Alles klar. Zurückspulen noch mal, dann habt ihr die Uhr. Henning, wo kann man dich finden?
Ja, ich heiße Henning Krause, aber die Mastodon Instanz ist sowas von unaufsprechlich. Das ist so ein französischer Nerd, der das für mich hustet. Aber ich glaube, wenn man im Chaosradio Feed guckt, dann findet man da irgendwelche Menschen. Was ich aber empfehlen möchte, ist der Account atprimes, at botsyn.space, der tutelt einfach Primzahlen.
Sehr geil.
Ja, ich würde jetzt auch Rixx das Ganze mit übernehmen, weil er bei dem Punkt mir die Akustik ja nicht so kennt. Von daher wäre es bei uns Rixx at chaos.social bzw. Leah at chaos.social.
Da könnt ihr gerne folgen. Und wenn ihr wissen wollt, was auf der chaos.social Instanz abgeht, ist der zugehörige Account Ordnung at chaos.social. Ein wichtiger Account, den man auch noch findet, ist Überraschung Chaosradio at chaos.social. Mein Name ist Monoxyd at mastodon.social und ich habe noch eine wichtige Nachricht für euch. Lasst euch nicht überwachen und verschlüsselt immer schön eure Backups.
Don't forget I'm in your extended network.